When you're building components,
it's a very common practice to reflect
the state of the component
using CSS classes.
For instance here is a toggle button
that I've built and when I click on it,
it's going to go into a pressed state.
And in order to style that state,
my JavaScript has added a pressed
class up here to my class list.
And because I want to have good
semantics, my JavaScript has also set
the aria-pressed state for
this toggle button to true.
And the style of a pressed state of the
button in my CSS, I have a selector that
targets any instance of the button
that has this pressed class.
Now a useful technique which we can
employ in this situation is to actually
remove this pressed class, and
instead replace it with aria attributes.
So I'm going to update the selector so
that it looks like this.
Here I'm using a CSS attribute selector
to target the element when
aria-pressed is true.
And the effect is the same as before,
but
now I get this nice verification that
I've set the aria state properly
because it's visually
reflected by my element.
Not to mention I can cut
down on some of my CSS noise
by getting rid of additional selectors
and replacing them with aria attributes.